[Musique]
des plages aux plaines en passant par
les montagnes la variété de paysages de
la Nouvelle-Zélande est inégalée
mais ce paradis naturel a longtemps été
confisqué au premier habitat tout comme
leur tradition
[Musique]
les territoires ancestraux et la culture
maori font aujourd'hui partie des
richesses du pays qu'il se réapproprie
[Musique]
dans la classe de Madame Tella les
enfants apprennent dans leur langue
l'éducation est un des piliers de cette
revitalisation depuis 1990 le
gouvernement finance des écoles
primaires d'immersion en maori comme
celle de retour roi
ces établissements reflètent les valeurs
traditionnelles dans le but de
revitaliser la langue mais aussi la
culture ce qui a fait augmenter le taux
de réussite des jeunes Maoris de quoi
émerveiller l'enseignante Tayla qui n'a
pas eu ce privilège lorsqu'elle était
toute jaune
[Musique]
mais aussi quelques cours offerts au
secondaire près de 30% des Néo-Zélandais
ont reçu de l'enseignement en Maouri
l'an dernier
mais pour ceux qui ne sont pas en
immersion l'apprentissage demeure
difficile le réflexe naturel et de
parler en anglais entre amis
malgré tout le gouvernement né aux
zélandais veut élargir l'éducation en
maori dans les prochaines années
[Musique]
le haka et le symbole le plus connu de
cette culture autochtone le rituel
guerrier a contribué à la perpétuer
grâce au touristes qui ont payé pour en
connaître davantage sur la culture et
pour visiter les merveilles naturelles
du site l'Institut d'artisanat maori de
Rotorua récupère une partie des recettes
pour financer l'apprentissage des
métiers d'art traditionnels
s les élèves et artistes sont les
gardiens du savoir autochtone dans
quelque sorte leur sculpture contribue à
la promotion et à la protection des
traditions Maoris
comme au Canada les territoires
ancestraux sont au cœur des relations
entre le gouvernement et les autochtones
des institutions conjoines gouvernement
et maori ont été créés pour formuler des
recommandations mais dans beaucoup de
cas comme ici à Rotorua la rétrocession
de territoire découle de longue
négociation
en 2006 14 lacs en pietretta ont été
restitués au maori après de longues
négociations en reconnaissance des torts
commis lorsqu'ils ont été bannis de leur
terre et plan d'eau
un organisme autochtone pour lequel
William à nos roues travaillent a été
créé pour rassurer la régénération de
l'écosystème
finnois
[Musique]
l'école à l'extérieur des élèves de la
région participent aux efforts de
protection William à nous roule leur
apprend à se débarrasser des espèces
invasives
le rapport à la Terre prend un tout
autre sens pour ses enfants qui pêchent
et profitent des lacs ce qui était
encore impensable il n'y a pas si
longtemps
institution unique le tribunal de White
Andy se penche sur de nombreuses
revendications territoriales du genre
mais elle ne dispose que de pouvoir de
recommandations dans certains cas les
travaux de l'organisme mènent à des
négociations gouvernementales mais pas
assez souvent selon la couchef du parti
maori qui réclame plus de pouvoir pour
le tribunal de White Andy
elle croit aussi que les préoccupations
Maoris sont souvent
ignorées en politique même si sur les
120 élus actuels 25 sont maori de plus
cette circonscriptions sont réservées
aux autochtones
[Applaudissements]
la tradition du haka avant un match de
rugby a été popularisé dans le monde par
l'équipe nationale les All Blacks mais
cette fois-ci le rituel est particulier
sous le regard de millions de partisans
du monde entier les meilleurs joueurs
maori affrontent les vedettes
autochtones australienne pour la
première fois en soldes
c'est l'occasion d'exprimer la fierté de
la nation maori selon cette partisane et
d'inspirer les autochtones de partout
[Musique]
malgré toutes les avancées et leur
statut de modèles de réconciliation
autochtone beaucoup restent encore à
faire pour les Maoris l'élimination de
la discrimination raciale et la
protection des territoires sacrés
demeurent un combat à long terme